in this next stretch work we're going to
use the tool on the neck but on a tall
back chair okay so what we'll do is for
her we're going to use the medium lift
for me I would use the big one here so
we're going to turn her around right
here and we're going to place this I
like to put the long ones on the bottom
here and this moment on the top but you
could easily do this as well
but this might kind of fall down so we
want to do it like this and then lean
back right where she has right
underneath the neck okay where it feels
comfortable and then she's going to just
going to just put some pressure there do
you feel pressure right there does that
feel good yeah so this she's doing
acupressure using your own body weight
tilted at an angle now I'm going to have
you slouched just a little bit slap your
butt down like put your legs out move
your butt more more and more right there
right there
now you see that you we put a little
more pressure because now her whole body
is leaning back on this so during the
day I have one of these chairs I will
just for two minutes
apply this little technique and I'm like
I'm ready for bed okay now this one you
can even do for it is up to five minutes
so we're doing the one right underneath
the neck right underneath the skull
right there but what she can do is push
it down one notch right there yeah you
feel that there so there's two segments
rent one right under the skull and then
one about a half an inch down the one a
half an inch down primarily focuses on
sinus and breathing so do you feel like
you can breathe any better because it'll
open up your breathing especially for
people who snore okay so if you to make
it easy all you have to do is start high
and then go low and you're looking for
that tightness okay so she'll do this
for a little while and then we can drop
it down even more right to here and
that's good for if you have a sore
throat or just to take away a lot of
stiffness in your neck
so you work that neck out and boy you're
going to be you're going to sleep really
really good okay so that's how you do
the neck so what I'm going to do Roxanna
let's go ahead and just stand up for a
second I'm going to sit down keep the
camera right there I'm going to sit
there and show you what how I do it okay
so we'll just swing back here and I'm
going to use a little bit taller okay so
if you can see this right like so right
there
so I'll just lay here and I'll just take
a nap for like about an hour so this is
pressing on the level where you're the
first vertebra on your neck okay and
then I'm going to push it down a little
bit lower right there and this is a
really good one too for breathing I'll
just work it out and I'll hold it for
about two minutes maybe three up to five
minutes and you just let your gravity
don't force it just let the head of your
weight go right into that those points
right there okay so that's how you would
do the neck points with the massage tool